ابرز الزلازل التي ضربت بلدان في العالم
بعد السادس من فبراير الحادي عشر من
فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.1 درجه ضرب تايوان
واخر بقوه 6 درجات قباله سواحل اندونيسيا
دون تسجيل خسائر الثاني عشر من فبراير هزه
ارضيه باقليم الحسيمه في المغرب بلغت
شدتها 4.3 درجه دون اضرار الرابع عشر من
فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.6 درجه جنوب شرقي
رومانيا لم يتسبب باضرار او اصابات شعر به
سكان بلغاريا وصربيا
الخامس عشر من فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.7 درجه
قرب العاصمه النيوزلنديه
الخامس عشر من فبراير تعرضت مدينه المرج
شرق ليبيا لهزه ارضيه دون خسائر وهي الهزه
الرابعه التي تسجل خلال الايام الماضيه
السادس عشر من فبراير هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه تسجل زلزالا بقوه 4.3
على مقياس ريختر ضرب ولايه تكساس
الامريكيه من دون ضحايا
السادس عشر من فبراير زلزال هز كرواتيا
بقوه خمس درجات ونصف دون ضحايا
وقبله بساعات ذكر مرصد الزلازل الاردني ان
منطقه الشمال البحر الميت تعرضت لهزه
ارضيه جديده بقوه 3.4 درجه